without further ado here we go
it will
john mike congratulations you've landed
yourselves in the final round of this
competition
now we're sending you back to your home
forge just to recreate an iconic weapon
from history that weapon is
the greek copis bladesmiths you'll have
five days at your home forges in which
to complete this challenge at the end of
those five days
you'll return and present your copisses
to our panel of expert judges
and after they've thoroughly tested the
hell out of them they'll declare one of
you the forest and fire champion who
leaves here with a check
for ten thousand dollars good luck blade
smiths we'll see you in five days
good luck good luck
feels great to be back in my home forge
i'm excited to get started i'm going to
do a wrap
or a sand my construction my damascus is
on the outside
there's a solid layer of 15n20 and then
down the center
is one solid piece of 5160. it should be
really pretty and tough
i'm back at the home forge and getting
ready to go this entire piece
is going to be made out of damascus with
an integral
guard and an integral pommel built into
it so
without further ado here we go if i at
the end of day
have a rough shape of a sword i'll be
really happy
it's 30 layers right now i'm gonna cut
it into
sections probably three to have a layer
count of about 90.
okay we had a long way to go
stay tuned i have to make some fullering
dyes for this blade
this is the bottom section of a railroad
track
to just round the top off to get the
right shape that i want
come on it's pretty good
the fuller lines are really clean
symmetrical
it's exactly what i was hoping for
to start at day three we're gonna work
on the
guard and the pommel we've got a lot of
work to do it's gonna be a lot of
detailed work
it's gonna be slow i feel like a dentist
and then i've got to quench the blades
everything that i've done since i've
picked up a hammer
is coming down to this point
[Music]
i hope that this works out it's
perfectly straight
i got a straight blade
it's day four i'm excited i think
basically i just have to finish up my
handle today
i'm gonna pin these two pieces of brass
to either side of the blade to hold them
in place
while i silver solder gonna heat up the
guard a little
let the heat travel up the blade and up
towards that solder
i think this sword is going to look
awesome the color combination with the
brass
and the dark handle scales it's just all
coming together
i'm really stoked but i still have one
more piece to meet parameters
i need to connect my pommel to the guard
this is going to go through the horse's
mouth
and it's going to bend in a v
and come down here into the guard i want
to make it look like
rain's coming from the horse's mouth
i like it that's good
this is the last day i've got to put
scales on
when your band saw breaks you got to
improvise i have
never put scales on a blade
that's got an integral pommel and guard
i just may have made a really really big
mistake my pin
doesn't fit right i drilled the wrong
hole
i'm in a panic mode so in day five i've
got to make a new handle
it's coming along now i'm feeling pretty
good
making this copis was a really really
tall order
i feel like i've done my best work that
i've
ever done as a bladesmith right now
it will cut all right bladesmiths to
find out what kind of lethal damage
your weapon will do i will take your
greek copus and deliver some killing
blows
in this ballistics dummy john york first
you ready
ready i'm pretty nervous there's no way
to prepare yourself
for this moment i'm just gonna hope that
my blade survives
[Music]
[Music]
all right john let's talk about your
copis here there is a little crack that
goes around the edge
on both sides when i saw the tip i
thought that gonna be tip heavy it's not
there's good recovery with this
it's a very powerful weapon sir it will
kill
thank you all right mike it's time to
have fun with your blade are you ready
i'm ready
[Music]
good job thanks all right mike let's
talk about your greek copis right here
it is heavier but every shot that i go
in there cuts
you have a sharp edge but more
importantly sir
it will kill thank you good job
[Music]
all right gentlemen it's time for the
strength test now to test the strength
durability and overall construction of
your greek copisses
i'll be attacking these two soldiers
john you're up are you ready
[Music]
ready
all right john first off that small
crack we noticed
has not opened up at all which is great
um your blade took some minor
deformation a
little bit of roll but uh overall it's a
strong blade
well done thank you all right mike
you're up you ready
i'm ready
all right so mike your edge took a
little bit of damage here
and then up here it just sort of peeled
a hair
off your edge but other than that this
blade is still
sharp all the way down um it's got some
heft to it but your handle construction
does make up for it
but most of all it's a strong blade nice
and comfy thank you
all right bladesmiths to test the edge
of your greek copis i will take your
weapon
and i will slice across these rugs john
your first you ready
ready
so
all right john the edge here is sharp on
this last one
not so much but as we can see on the
other rugs it will cut
thank you all right mike it's your turn
you ready i'm ready
[Music]
all right mike first up the forward
weight that you have on your blade here
lets yourself to do a beautiful vertical
cut
but on a diagonal cut because of the
forward weight being there it feels more
like a chopper than a slasher so
it cut in but it didn't slice in to
control that
it's a sharp edge and it'll cut
thank you john mike both of you made
high performance blades that did
very well in our weapons tests our next
forged and fire champion is
john congratulations you're the new
forest of fire champion
mike i want you to know that the judges
and i are proud as hell of what you've
turned in man
it was a competitive blade and it really
did come down
to the finest details but i have to ask
you to please surrender your copis
that really makes me feel good that the
judging was so close
this competition was really tough for me
it tested a lot of new skills that i
hadn't done before
it was a big win for myself it was a
great competition and a great experience
and i'd do it all over
again john congratulations you're our
new force and fire champion and that's
the title that comes with a check for
ten thousand dollars
please present your blade to the judges
i'm unbelievably happy i'm a new blade
smith and it's something
that i want to do in the future to
walk into this world of bladesmithing
and then join
forged in fire and compete and win it it
doesn't get any better than that